Maps can suffer from poor coloring as well,
let's look at a few examples on this catastrophe blog.
This first map was submitted by a wind energy company looking to
build more wind farms.
The map shows the expected amount of noise that the wind farm was
going to generate.
As you can see, this map suffers from high contrast and bright colors.
This map further down is just a sea of black labels.
You can't actually make out many of the labels in here.
If you have more time, I recommend reading through some of these examples to
get a better idea of how you can utilize color in your own visualizations.
The good news is, is that even if you're not sure which colors to use,
there's a wealth of resources at your disposal.
Cynthia Brewer, a Professor of Geography at Penn State, developed ColorBrewer.
Which contains a set of web, print, and color blind friendly colors.
While her work mainly focused on maps,
many of the color sequences, including sequential, diverging and
qualitative can be effective choices when creating most data visualizations.
And if you want even more color palettes, you can check out Adobe's cooler
to either pick popular ones, or create your own.
The links to those websites can be found in the instructor's notes.